[Music]
okay so this is my review
of your honor episode three as always
it's directed by edward berger but this
is the first episode where we change
writer here with allison mcdonald taking
over
i'm gonna break this review up into
three parts i first want to tackle
michael and adam's first half of their
story
then we'll go into lee and kofi's story
and we'll finish off with the baxters
and then we'll come to where all the
storylines come together because this is
the first episode things get a little
more complicated and new developments
are
kind of showing at the same time and
making this a little more
interesting so i was really worried here
in this episode because i feel like
this episode had the slowest 15 minutes
of the series so far and that was at the
beginning here
they had this song playing by leonard
cohen treaty
they even played it twice the montage
was too slow
even the scene with michael here getting
rid of the gas station footage
it dragged on a bit the whole first 15
minutes of this episode
really could have been chopped up to get
this going a little quicker so an
interesting development here is
adam now his character more and more is
feeling prisoner
of his own feelings of guilt and wanting
to be set free of this secret he's
holding
and we see that him bringing the truth
is coming out in other ways and
right now he's doing it through photos
he's taking because he believes
these photos are a way he can kind of
show what really happened
he's taking photos of his injury he's
taking photos of the crime scene
he's even taking photos of the prison
and we already saw how much
he wants to feel what he believes he
deserves and you see that
last episode when he's standing in place
of kofi in the courtroom and now you see
it here in the scene where he's in the
elevator
and he's telling the two other guys who
are charged with misdemeanors that
he was charged for murder the angle i
really liked here
that they did with michael's storyline
and character
is that he's trying to have his cake and
eat it too
meaning this episode really develops
well that he wants his son to go free
not get caught for what he did but he
doesn't want anyone else taking the
blame for
it and that's kofi so there is a ounce
of humanity left in michael
and that he's still trying to do the
right thing for kofi
while clearing his son's name so it
complicates things even more
i think it would have been really boring
if they just went with him full-on
committing to letting other people take
the blame but
it makes it so much more interesting
that he's trying to
somehow do the right thing in all the
things he's messing up on and that's why
it made it so interesting having
this lee story develop now with kofi
which we'll get into
but it's interesting that charlie here
flips out
on michael saying now you're gonna get
me in trouble
i was helping out i'm involved with this
felony here
what is your problem for getting lee
involved but it's almost like michael
takes from charlie
this little moment he says that are you
banging lee
and that's the only way you're going to
manage her because he ends up kissing
liability in this episode he definitely
was already into her but
i feel like he's going to escalate
things because he knows he's going to
have to keep an eye on her and make sure
she's just following the path he set out
for her
i also think it's hysterical when we go
back to adam's story that
he is still developing photos in a dark
room in 2020
and i get what they were doing
artistically with him having
a vision of him dancing and being free
but
i'm going to act like that didn't happen
because it just came off comical to me i
was laughing at
seeing hunter doing show off his dance
moves here i also think it's
really strange that the character of
franny who's his teacher that we know
from episode one he's been sleeping with
that they cast her as someone who looks
exactly the same age
as adam it's a little puzzling and
confusing because there's a subconscious
part of me and i think other viewers can
relate where you think
she's like a co-student and it makes it
look less scandalous as it being a
teacher
which it should look and it's also
strange because there's a line here
where michael says to franny
you know when his mom died you were
there for him you comforted him i think
that would have worked as an older
figure it's kind of just
not giving the effect i feel like it
needs by having someone who looks
exactly the same age
but we'll see how it plays out now two
scenes that really stood out to me the
first one
is i love all these 10 scenes that we
have is detective costello here
played by amy landecker and she has
another good one here at the dinner
table
with adam and michael i think all fans
of breaking bad and brian cranston are
going to love scenes where
michael has his back against the woman
has to talk his way out of it just like
walter white always had to do
and you see detective castell is clearly
suspicious of michael and adam and
that's what i'm loving about what this
show's doing right now is it's
adding so many factions here that can
mess everything up for michael there's
so many
layers and moving parts and it makes it
that more interesting in a story that i
was worried could get bland because we
already know what happened at the crime
scene but
they're making it really intriguing and
how many
parties are involved and how many things
can mess up our protagonists here
in michael and his plan now my favorite
scene of brian cranston so far acting
wise
end of hunter doing here is when adam
calls out michael
for acting and pretending like
everything's normal and okay
and brings up that tomorrow is a funeral
for the boy he killed and i love he's
like so we're just gonna pretend they're
not burying him tomorrow and michael
goes
yes yes that was brian cranston at his
best
he always hits the spot of fully
invested in his character
genuine emotion never overacting and it
just felt like that scary dad moment i
think most people have experienced their
life at some point or another or
witnessed maybe one of their friend's
dads
freaking out like that and that's such
an effective moment because we see
how frantic michael's character has been
this whole show and hasn't even taken a
minute to process
really what he's doing and that was like
a moment for him to show that
anger and fire he has just brewing
coming out now i want to shift over to
kofi and lee's story here
it's interesting because it's giving
kofi an option now to plea not guilty
and that lee is gonna spin this as
police brutality
to force the da's hand here to just drop
the case which michael wants
for kofi the weird thing i do wonder
though here and again we have to see how
this develops is what michael's plan is
now if he is protective of kofi's life
and him getting innocence that how is he
going to handle the baxter faction of
this he's already having trouble with it
in this episode but
if kofi's let out of jail it almost
exposes him more to the baxters so i
don't think
any point of kofi is going to leave this
story it's always going to be an
obstacle
for michael trying to keep him alive and
well
just like his son he's almost now
carrying the loads of two people
and that's where we're saying all these
interesting things that make this even
more messy is that
the crooked cop who is in touch with
the gang leader here for kofi is getting
worried now that he's pleading not
guilty and that makes you wonder now
what's going to happen
to kofi's family because that was not
the deal kofi made he was supposed to
say he's guilty so
again just so many factions of
interesting conflict here which i'm
really digging
and then shifting gears now to the
baxter storyline here i love that we see
gina baxter played by hope davis who
does a great job this episode
really takes the spotlight now and we
get now
brought into the story of carlo baxter
the brother who's in jail
now gina has this brilliant plan this is
what she says in the episode is gonna be
their big move to just
end this conflict they think with this
gang is that
she's gonna get her son to the funeral
so she got a moment to whisper to him
and tell him to take care of kofi and we
see gina's this mastermind cause she's
bribing people here to even get him at
this funeral
and she's got her head more on her
shoulders and a plan of action where
jimmy baxter is broken right now and we
even see him say a line here that he
feels guilt for his son's death because
he bought him that bike but
you see gina here just instead of being
a
sad mom they've given her character now
a motive and an eye on the ball here
where
jimmy's kind of the one flustered so
where the story lines now that we've
talked about so far all come together
is really effective in one episode at
this
funeral scene and everything ramps up
now because now michael's putting it
together
his fear of already hearing carlo baxter
might go this funeral earlier in the
episode
now he sees he's there so he literally
runs
to make a phone call to get kofi moved
because he knows exactly
what the baxters are planning here but
remember this gets messed up his
protection plan of moving kofi because
he's talking to an unreliable
cop on the other end who's more focused
on the sports game so we can assume that
he didn't get kofi
moved in time but that's why it's so
important that kofi's prison mate here
who's looking out for him
basically gives him really good advice
that you're not gonna beat the baxters
you know
they're dangerous in every facet but we
can assume he's told kofi to
try to make some kind of deal and just
go talk to him
carlo bax before he just whacks you so
that leads to the end of this episode
where
that's kind of a big choice in its own
right that kofi's kind of just taking
things in his own hands here
now what i didn't really like though was
when we see
lee informs michael that she's already
gotten the charges dropped by the da
and her plan is worked to get kofi free
and she said he's gonna be free in the
morning
that to me moved a little fast because
that story was just developed in this
episode and for her to quickly
get that d.a convinced i don't know that
felt like lightning speed to resolve the
conflict
so be it but i wasn't really crazy about
that it just felt
off pace of the pace the show has been
going in resolving its conflicts
so that's where maybe pacing issues
could arise where
you have one solved really quick but
other things are seen kind of played out
at a very slower pace just kind of make
you feel a little bit
out of reality but again not too crazy
of a deal so what is interesting though
is in the development here of adam's
story where he tells franny now
we knew this was coming what really
happened so she's actually
not the third party to know what really
happened that day she's really the
fourth party and the third
other party which i didn't mention yet
but when
adam was taking photos of the crime
scene again this mysterious black car
that was telling him the day of the
accident
sees he's doing this so this car
definitely really knows what went down
here
or has a good idea of it by that day
following him and then leaving the scene
then seeing him taking photos at the
scene we don't know who this is
so it's the fourth faction here the
mystery that's really kind of
behind the show right now which i really
like to have that too but what's so
interesting about franny knowing now
is it's just gonna be something that's
gonna piss michael
off that she knows and it actually puts
franny at risk now to michael how far
will michael go
to have to deal with someone like franny
if she gets in the way of his plan and
it might be the
catalyst now that's pushing adam to be
truthful we'll see
again i like the show is adding all
these factions and
things that can mess up michael's plan
all these challenges but
they got to stick to landing the more
pieces you lay out here on the
chessboard
it's going to make it harder to do that
but let's just have faith because right
now it's really interesting and it's
working so this was actually
my favorite episode so far i'm giving it
a 9.1
i think that it did have the weakest 15
minutes of the show yet like i said
in the open but it then had i would
argue
the best second half of any episode so
far and really exciting stuff and it
kind of showed you like oh okay this is
where we're going now this
is getting interesting gina baxter's
interesting kofi story is interesting
and why
lee works in that story and how
michael's trying to control all these
things
and i again really think the best choice
i made as writers here was that
michael was gonna still have some of his
old self in him and try to keep kofi
safe while trying to the impossible and
keep his son
out of this without someone else taking
the blame
that's what's so interesting and i love
they went that way
and again brian cranston and hunter
doing too here that scene
again in the kitchen where he confronts
him about pretending about all this and
then he snaps was
excellent excellent stuff so i'm really
excited now i'm really feeling this show
and where it's gonna go i'm hooked now i
was intrigued the first two
now i'm hooked i want to see the next
episode i want to see where this is
going
let me know what you thought of it down
below i'd love to hear your thoughts i
read every comment and try to respond as
many as i can
please make sure to subscribe to my
channel if you don't miss one of my
reviews of your honor i'll be doing
every episode i also have reviews of
servant coming out soon
i do a bunch of tv shows movie reviews
as well i also do celebrity interviews
you're gonna want to check those out and
if you like what i do here
i'd really appreciate a donation to my
channel it's two dollars a month there's
a link down below
it really will help me be able to do
this full time and make more videos for
you guys
i'll be forever grateful and please
follow me at steve varley show on
twitter instagram for more of me
and i'll see you next time